tonton je vais je vais fermer mais deux
trois petits trucs
allez tu là on va alors ce soir ce soir
ce soir ce soir c'est le tournoi ce soir
c'est le tournoi et est donc est donc
celle ouais c'est le grand tournant à
bitstream du mois premiers jeudis du
mois et on va tout de suite on va tout
de suite le le programme est alors
tournoi club on va commencer à 20h35 on
va se faire du 3 plus de moi j'aime bien
le 3 + 2 on va se faire cinq rondes
ça me paraît bien et on va se mettre à
23h35 et on va appeler tournoi mensuel
midstream même tournoi mensuel tiens on
va on va carrément faire toi mensuel
nous sommes au dessus de tout
conceptuellement nous sommes au dessus
et on est quand même en tournois
mensuels
moi je suis très content du nom elle m'a
fait très plaisir là tout d'un coup mais
je suis très très heureux je vais ouvrir
le chat de twitch et duchess comme jeu
pour avoir un petit ralentissement de
connexion j'ouvre je suis mis une
meilleure qu'une meilleure qualité
aujourd'hui meilleure qualité vidéo du
fait de la non présence de fabien fabien
qui est qui en australie je vous
rappelle après m'avoir à vérifier si ça
marche on m'écrit you dans le chat c'est
que ça doit marcher on va vérifier quand
même on écrivait yacht partout on
imagine que ça marche mais je vous
laisse me répondre papa ou de le chat
ap on va fermer ça
dont confirmé moins bien je dois pas vos
messages j'espère comme tv oui ok mac ce
qui me dit que ça marche donc ce soir je
vous rappelle ll tornay le tournoi
bitstream et on a le chat alors est ce
que on va juste se prendre la pub et
ouais ça ne va juste un poil nous
ralentir internet mais ça ça va passer
après je prends la publicité de vos
propres stream on m'écrit omelette ou
fromage eux
[Musique]
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas donc ce
tournoi alors pour s'inscrire je pense
que vous savez comment faire moment il
ya que max âge qui inscrit à l'est on
s'inscrit on s'inscrit premier jeudi du
mois j'avais sur les discordes faut en
parler à tout le monde
faut en parler à tout le monde font
parler un maximum de personnes de ceux
de ce tournoi je pense que vous le
connaissez maintenant mais peut-être que
tout le monde n'a pas réalisé que
c'était le 7 mai où sa tombe le 1er
jeudi
c'est le premier que je vais faire nous
dit nous dit max où il est inscrit et
pour le moment il est seul donc il est
bien parti pour le remporter ce tournoi
je vais faire un jeu faire un petit jeu
vers un petit message sur facebook
je vais faire un petit message sur
facebook salut à ethan sayah qui
arrivait
sur athènes ça qui arrive et on va
essayer sur facebook de
de mettre un petit message n'oubliez pas
ce soir à 20h35 le tournoi de blitz trim
sur chess com
allez hop j'ai mis le petit j'ai mis un
petit message facebook messages facebook
qui fait plaisir
donc mon sommes nous en sommes nous en
sommes nous nous sommes de nous avons et
aïn taya qui est arrivé il est il est de
partout il est complètement de partout
et non seulement sur le chat mais il est
aussi sur le tournoi
on espère qu'il est en forme
coco walker
comment on s'inscrire à cocoa le coeur
je sais pas si tu me troll mais c'est
sur la page live de tchatche.com nom ne
commençait pas ne commençait pas soyez
sympa à on may cry 2 partout comment on
fait bon faut déjà être inscrit au club
bleed stream ça c'est le truc important
de base
donc si vous n'êtes pas inscrit au club
liste rim on est mal les mecs je vais
jouer envoyez un lien vers parce que ça
ça commence à me demander là ça commence
un
ça commence à me demander de partout
comment fait-on la grégoire et chéquiers
l'air deux des trois bien joué hier
second duo title fusée ouest avant-hier
même grégoire face a fini dans la nuit
donc oui quelque part c'était hier c'est
fini dans la nuit du mardi au mercredi
cette histoire alpha 0 sera-t-il présent
au tournant à 12 - deux des buts en 71
matchs à zéro j'ai l'impression qu'il
est complètement dans l'esprit 1
honnêtement donc quelque part son esprit
sera dans le tournoi il n'y a pas de ce
pitch est sûre tu as comme ce soir c'est
écrit sur sa chaise comme je comprends
pas bah je suis un speech et à ce soir
je suis juste pas au courant ce qui
serait étonnant mais bon maintenant je
crois pas
je crois pas du tout mais y'a peut-être
j'ai failli à pas les dates je pense
pour le prochain match
je crois que ça va être le 15 mai que
les dates sont pas confirmés je suis pas
sûre de cette information
c'est une information ne pas prendre
faut faire un didacticiel est collé de
la vidéo à chaque fois qu'ils organisent
un tournoi way faudrait il faudrait
faudrait des buts en 71
mais bon du coup comme on commence un
peu en avant on explique à chaque fois
c'est pas grave mais pas comment on peut
demander que 3g dès qu'ils y arrivent
bintou play games morneau we are going
to make to make de tournament tonight
bis rim tournament of demande enfin j'ai
envie de tenir
nous sommes sur le tour abyss renew
moins
envoyez fischer 2 qu'il y aille salut
bobby fischer deux salles usep chat ça
commence à arriver ça a commencé à
arriver a dit pas si vrai pour pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi ça ne
s'inscrit pas pourquoi les gens ne
s'inscrivent pas que se passe-t-il que
se passe-t-il
que se passe t'il une somme que trois
sets ça c'est sympa on va voir regarder
les parties et partie des joueurs
je suis dans le club - reste à trouver
le tournant alors le tournoi faut que tu
ailles sur czech comme plaît enfin sur
le live donc le jeu en direct tu vas tu
cliques sur sur échec en direct et une
fois que tu es sur échec en direct tu
tues tu as tu as les tournois ou là j'ai
fait n'importe quoi tu allais tournoi tu
vas dans tournoi mensuel et hu devraient
le voir dans les premiers
je laisse ou légion en ce moment c'est
écrit première demi finale 27 sain et
deuxième c'est de gouverner que tu
verras un poste fixe ou pour l'annoncer
le tuera pas dans une vidéo oui je fais
toujours une vidéo bronzette shot pour
pour
pour annoncer les matchs de ce pitch est
ce donc ce qui se passe c'est quoi le
meilleur truc pour ne pas rater c'est
soit d'être sur le facebook bitstream
soin de suivre les vidéos
quotidiennement tout le temps partout
l'ide stream et du coup tu es sûr de ne
jamais rater un speech est surtout que
le prochain match sera hyper hyper hyper
hyper intéressant parce que je prévois
une grosse surprise
et oui je prévois la victoire de
car yakine se rassurent nakamura a je le
dis moi je suis comme ça on préfère
regarder que de jouer aux échecs
beaucoup de gens jouent mais peu qu'on
prenne au football peu de gens jouent
mais tout le monde comprend
anatoly coop karpov à moi je préfère
regarder que jouèrent pas on remarque
juste ça mais ce peuvent pas forcément
vraiment blidge à venir mixer mais
j'aime beaucoup les speechs s en fait a
commenté et les title tune des ajouts et
pourquoi je joue pas le tournoi est à
annemasse déjoué plusieurs fois et en
fait
bah faut à chaque fois plus ou moins je
le gagne et du coup je me dis que c'est
plus drôle de commenter les parties au
moins les gens qui jouent bien ils
peuvent ils peuvent revoir en replay
puis peut-être apprendre des choses
surtout quand je suis seul quand je suis
avec fable on se marre et tout ça là je
vais vraiment quand on fait des blagues
et où c'est un peu l'objectif quand on
est en duo et qu'on commente autant là
on va vraiment suivre les parties on va
vraiment regarder et peut-être que les
gens qui jouent bas ils sont contents
d'avoir leur parti analysé de voir un
peu le ressenti quelqu'un de plus fort
en fait je pense que c'est intéressant
pour les gens qui jouent vous m'avez
déjà vue jouer et rejouer sur rejouer
lobby sioniste car yakine va perdre
aretz il va gagner
bonne soirée bronzette shot qui ne reste
donc pas pour le tournoi pour cette
chaude qui rate qui raclent tournoi le
plus important de l'année puisque c'est
le dernier tournoi bitstream 2017
peut-être peut-être peut-être on
pourrait peut-être se faire un petit
tournoi post noël ou quelque chose comme
ça on en discutera sur le discorde
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas un stream
un stream du 25 décembre le soir
histoire de se faire une petite soirée
tournoi je dis ça je dis rien je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez dans le chat
mais 25 décembre le soir de façon c'est
un peu le jour où de toute façon tu as
eu le réveillon le 24 tu as eu le
déjeuner en famille
le 25 et tu te dis tu te dis bon ben il
est temps de il est temps de se reposer
le soir on pourrait certes être un petit
stream un petit stream un petit tournoi
abonnés joyeux noël quoi du mondial-2010
hâtives on allait on commençait et enfin
on commence à 20h35 donc il va farhat en
on edisson et nice
on est dix on est là on est solides
prendra effet le tournoi bitstream dans
la soirée spéciale 7000 abonnés on avait
été 90 jours avant le tournoi c'est un
des plus gros tournois check point com
or title cusey à savoir faut le savoir
mais lg d un st est pas content il veut
qu'on joue
non mais c'est une soirée c'est une
soirée sympa ça permet aux gens d'un
petit peu d'un petit peu faire ce
tournoi et où il ya le charpentier qui
arrivait à thomas mux donc ça c'est
cette idée de tournoi le 25
qu'est ce que vous en pensez le 25 au
soir
est ce que c'est une idée vous dites ah
c'est un peu la bonne idée puisque
germain en fait c'est vraiment de la
merde cette idée à nyon où je m'en fous
on peut aussi répondre notre fais ce que
tu veux
un stream de 31 millions le 31 à minuit
je n'y aura pas de frime c'est sûr
sur nous au niveau du sondage sur les
commentateurs préférés j'ai pas fait de
sondage bva fait de sondage
il faudrait comment faire pour partie
clôture allemande m'a dit dhabi graydon
alors pour participer au tournoi il te
faut déjà être membre du club bitstream
sur trois points comme donc ce serait à
ce point comme snatch club cela le
bitstream je pense que c'est ça le luart
est je suis pas les regarder mais je
suis quasi sûr dabul tour qui salue
kalenji matin en europe les deux rives
sont attachés avec karl cents à est
vraiment les meilleurs coups du tennis
sur toute la sur toutes les parties
cette soirée de grâce quand même - ouais
c'est pas mal faire un bon coup droit
mon revers quoi service aussi c'était
pas mal j'ai pas réussi à poser la volée
qu'il fallait à la fin non nitrox plaît
pourquoi vlad ne commente pas le tournoi
du jeudi avec des beats débutants comme
moi il pourrait trop les a augmentées ça
serait marrant est ce serait drôle ce
serait drôle c'est pas faux c'est pas
faux mais mon vlad là beaucoup de boulot
avec great flu qui s'est qualifiée pour
les candidats c'est pas facile donc
doivent participer au club liszt crime
après aller dans le shaq jeux en direct
et après une fois que tu es dans et
chaque jeu en direct
tu trouveras le tournoi dans la rubrique
tournois avec thomas mix n'est pas
encore inscrits se dit j'ai le temps je
réussis la m'inscrire il me reste 20
minutes
le charpentier non plus mais on a un
onzième joueur
malgré tout ça le fait marrer
lol juste l'alcool ça fait simplement
rire thomas vu que c'est inscrit toi vu
que c'est inscrit
nous sommes onze si je me suis inscrit
tu vois que tu es en favori pour les
candidats perçoit rogne alors un ronia
n'a jamais vraiment parfait dans les
candidats il a souvent craqué sous la
pression psychologique alors est ce que
ce sera encore le cas pour ces candidats
là ou pas je ne sais pas mais moi je
vous mets comme favori great choc parce
que vlad est ce que vous l'adorez
secondes et un nouvel s'ils s'étaient
qualifiés dans les seconds en change pas
des équipes comme ça en route
tu peux pas quitter un joueur pour un
autre si facilement au top niveau fin tu
peux mais ça se fait pas comme ça
les joueurs y gardent souvent leur
seconde en pendant quelques années voire
plus
donc non
vous l'assuré rester avec grille tube de
toute façon dès 8 ans y est on fabrique
sans parti pris pour une fois même est
bon très difficile de pas avoir de parti
pris 1 j'ai mon parti pris tu vois je
prends le parti
mais bon il ya caruana aussi sans
rigoler qui sera meilleurs lots du
tournoi et qui domine londres en ce
moment donc il faut pas enfin tout le
monde peut gagner en fait c'est serré
quand même car yakine derrière mais bon
karine chaussures a du mal à organiser
un peu extraordinaire la dernière fois
mais comme c'est un tournant aux
personnes prend de risque qui joue très
solide et mais bon je le vois pas gagner
du tout car y'a qui met même ont tissé
cramique non plus je pense que le
tournoi est trop long et qui craquera
mais bon pareil qui sait lellouche 6
britannia 66 qui est arrivé sur sur le
chat 1 et toujours on vous allez allez
on se bat on s'inscrit on s'est inscrits
de partout
inscrivons nouveaux candidats non pas
aux candidats quand ils assez dur de
s'inscrire enfin on peut essayer de
s'inscrire mais personne ne va nous
laisser jouer le tour a admis seront
beaucoup plus difficiles
quelque part on se demande toujours pas
comment le tournoi il porte un nom je
n'en vois que trois ans corp a commencé
à s que tu es dans le club blitz rim
jouffre est ce que tu es membre du club
bitstream c'est un peu la question qu'on
se pose parce que si tu ne l'est pas si
tu ne les pas du coup tu ne peux pas
quelque part le voir
bon c'est un peu la question qu'on se
pose en ce moment sur sur le stream j'ai
envie de te dire il va faire des grog
caveau candidats ça allait calibrer je
pense aller mais trempé elle s max ou
qu'ils ont clos en clash quoi elle s'est
mise trophée je suis à 400 trophée le
prince est trop fort je n'arrive pas à
le stopper
faut que tu mettes des petites unités
pour stopper le prince genre par exemple
des petits gobelins
mais des petits gobelins où tu mets des
petits squelettes et du coup il va
perdre beaucoup de temps à aller taper
et toi avec ta tour temps verra des
flèches et tu le tuera gens bien que la
machine alpha 0 après le crise yahoo
soit ce serait dingue
elle obtiendrait un niveau de ouf très
rapidement en 1992 qui salue les tontons
salue ton ton salut tonton
ni toujours douze journées toujours vous
allez allez allez on se bouge un petit
peu mal phase 0 il pourrait juste
apprendre tout quoi reprendre tous les
toutes les formes d'échec alors si tu as
inscrit au club photo tide en échec en
direct et une foire échec en direct sur
la plate-forme de jeux en direct il faut
que tu trouves tournoi et une fois que
tu as trouvé tournoi c'est bon salut
pigiste rateront 17 arrêts ce que t'es
inscrit au club lite stream c'est un peu
la question que je me pose
même complètement
attends de ta réponse je passe un petit
décalage entre ce que je dis et où ça
arrivera aussi possible là on est
toujours 12
alors non il joue mais jargon tout
laisse pas encore info de taille sur
check point comme slash club cela je lis
rim là du coup vous participiez au club
billy stream très important bonsoir
bonsoir super tu as magna et une fois
que sera inscrit au club
ciao blisstree faudrait que tu ailles
sur la sueur sur la plateforme échec en
direct comme militant je te vois ici
surtout il fait surtout à ce point comme
blue partout tout le temps
ok c'est bon et donc après tu peux aller
sur sur check points comme cela show
live et dans les tournois tu verras le
tournoi bitstream il faudra simplement y
participer
et normalement ce sera bon tu sauras
participer au tournoi bitstream chose
comme importantissime un peu deux types
de personnes sur terre ce qu'ils peuvent
participer au tour abyss rim et les
autres tu fera partie de de ceux qui
peuvent le faire tu seras
conceptuellement au dessus des autres et
donc personne ne m'a répondu pour mon
idée tournoi le 25 au soir un tout le
monde s'en fout toi tu en penses quoi
bonne idée une soixante va pas le jouer
ouais tu vas pas dépensé une bonne idée
quand même a donc là automatiquement
j'ai un allié de poids alors on et 17 ça
commence à arriver
ça commence à arriver de plus en plus ça
commence à se bouger un petit peu
parent qui dictera la paix si elle
tournoi 20-20 il écrit que tu auras la
paix si à le tournoi tu auras la paix
pis ce sera tranquille
le 25 décembre
non je bats est écrit juste comme ça tu
vois mon chien level 3 en ternant mais
le 31 le 31 ans par le 31 on fera autre
chose
trente et un patron aliéna non 31 ans tu
vois c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est toi
qui est contre ce tournant du 31 mai
bonté contre le temps est trop tard son
tour a jusqu'en terre
alors le loup jolie britannique inédit
c'est bon j'ai rejoint donc on est
maintenant 20 il reste treize minutes
salut crise au 31
non il est pas de speechless aujourd'hui
pommes qu'ils vont jouer et rejoint avec
mon lots exceptionnels de 9 cents ça va
faire des étincelles
le vendent rage pas sûr à beaucoup de
monde dix pourraient le 25 le search
parce que vous faites un mois
généralement je suis arrivé en fait le
24 le soir oui le 25 à midi oui mais le
25 le soir tu es vraiment je fais rien
mais chassez gfi est pas content et très
très mécontents why not english i parce
que c'est un vide ce friendstream note
date bad ass porn
c'est intrigant français se fera et du
stream s'est exposé aux contres - non
mais tu peux jouer le tournoi n'a ce
soir c'est le tournevis rim tous les
premiers jeudis du mois
donc là on est premiers jeudis du mois
jeudi 7 décembre et du couteau en
bitstream tenu ici je fais je fête noël
le 24 au soir mais en fait tout une fête
noël le 24 au soir
les gens fous les gens fêtent le noël le
25 je ne sais pas en fait je me rends
pas compte mais j'ai l'impression qu'on
fait le noël le 24 le soir et confins
des jeunes est de 25 le déjeuner de noël
mais j'ai l'impression que le 25 le soir
on fait rien on va où c'est moi enfin je
sais pas est ce que le racing ce plan
comme c'est le même que l'it chasse dans
le reee team fj.com est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus proche de la réalité d'un
monsieur qui dit non tu peux les 3 100
points par rapport à lydia soit
exactement mais ressemblera plus à un
classement réel du coup donc nous sommes
20 nous sommes 20 nous sommes 20 on est
notre chatte que tu lis la kevin stp je
n'ai rien ici la highway je lis et relis
les deux chat en fait joli de partout je
lis le chat
twitch et je lis ce chat là je lis les
deux chat
je lis tous les tchats
donc justifier comment il fait 24 le
soir et mis 25 me dit habituellement
du coup je suis pas à la rue du coup 25
le soir vous fait quoi des généralement
c'est un peu la question que je me pose
est là aussi trop pressé bonsoir à toi
je suis regardé ce qui se passait il
vaut facebook réseaux sociaux pour voir
si mon message que je veux pas faire
sauter la connexion je suis en 4g sur le
téléphone
c'est plus pratique on va voir s'il ya
des gens qui ont écrit pour savoir
comment s'inscrire autour de 8 ce crime
en fait un tac tac tac boum a pas de
message in box bon y archives de cirque
qu'est ce que c'est que ça il ya spam et
de tous ok est ce qu'il ya des gens qui
ont répondu au truc ou pas
kevin vous duplaix we are going to watch
tournant maintenant oui je crois aussi
que le 25 au soir c'est la glandouille
pour tout le monde je pense on se remet
de sa gueule de bois et on est son
manque de sommeil est exact nous l'idée
de faire un petit tournoi en mode
tranquille mais je sais pas a voir mais
si vous n'êtes pas vraiment chaud on
fera pas dire et j'en rediscuterai sur
le discorde
il n'y a pas énormément de monde qui a
conduit m on se rappelait le tournoi
quelques personnes donc ça c'est cool je
passerai un peu vu le alpha 03 quand
même assez impressionnant
ces intelligences artificielles
du coup c'est quand le prochain
speech est sur le site officiel c'est
tout je pense que ça doit être le 15
comment tu accompagnes fiancée
apprécie-t-elle le temps passé pour la
chaîne je sais pas comment tu apprécié
le temps passé sur la chaîne les gens
demandent tu t'en fous complètement bête
non je pense très très contente plus de
temps passe plus de temps sur cette
chaîne youtube que je ne te vois pas sur
quel chat il faut communiquer pour
t'avoir alors volts rivoire soit sur le
chat de check point comme seul htv soit
sur le chat de twitch les deux j'ai les
deux chat ouvert donc je suit partout
alors ça peut être très content du tout
rond elle 25 ans mais moi aussi je pense
est une bonne idée pour ça une petite
soirée comme ça tranquille où un sans
prétention georges joyeux noël machin
que tu tournoi tranquille enfin vraiment
sans prétention n'en moddeurs votre
vacances en mode heures tranquilles ou
quoi ici je parle sur les buts tu vas
devenir fou et
suit partout c'est que 1700 mais mille
sept cent mille sept cent pour le
tournoi tu serai classé tête de série
numéro 3 a donc automatiquement tu as
toutes tes chances dans ce soir pas de
parties de bissau être y voir ce soir
tournoi tournoi bitstream kiné bad qui
débute dans six minutes donc j'en ai
très très content avoir des partis on
est 22 allée on est 22 on se bat peut
peut-être monter à 30 qui sait sur les
cinq minutes un espèce de rush
une chevauchée fantastique dirais-je est
ce que le discorde alors qu'est ce qui
se sait que discorde
ils sont partout il s'explique comment
participer aux trucs sur le discorde
quarante quatre personnes alors sur le
discours dans ce monde connecté il se
bat bien non il ne reste plus que cinq
minutes à jouer à cache hbcd dans le
tournoi ce soir ya l'om joue contre qui
marseille c'est l'europa league web
je suis pour marseille 1-2 base plutôt
mais enfin je m'en fiche du football se
lançant je regarde plus je regarde plus
que le rugbyman en mai de base j'étais
plutôt pour marseille c'est pas très
loin de chez moi
mais ouais je sais même pas qui a match
et puis l'europa league on puisse faire
aucun intérêt d'après moi il mérite dans
lequel dix cordes le discorde 2
de la communauté bitstream un excellent
discorde discorde dans l'esprit j'ai
envie de dire complètement au dessus
conceptuellement
il reste 5 minutes c'était quatre
minutes qui va réussir à s'inscrire qui
ne va pas réussir c'est la question
qu'on se pose le lien du discorde alors
attends je vais essayer de trouver ça tu
veux participer aux dix cornes
leader sur sous toutes les vidéos
surtout surtout toutes les vidéos
blisstree il ya le lien de du discorde
mais ce parti peut discorde il ya tout
le temps du monde de plus en plus de
monde
alors on est 24 aces quatre minutes
il reste quatre minutes dont ils
marchent bien discorde j'aime bien petit
à petit on a quand même réussi à en
faire quelque chose de ce discorde
du coup
ça avance petit à petit façon là les
gens à s qui m'écrivent ou pas dans ça
va j'ai plus de messages
bonsoir philibert chess 12
gentil mais écrire là dessus aussi
je pense que le stage au maroc avait
l'air vraiment sympa quand un prochain
stage à sept prochains stages ça va être
en juin on est plus ou moins un train de
finaliser la destination l'hôtel et tout
ça va falloir attendre encore un petit
peu peut-être une seule peut-être deux
trois semaines encore et après on
annoncera les inscriptions il y aura
très peu de place un jeu prévient déjà
il y aura très peu de place au prochain
stage déjà pas mal de choses qui sont
préservés donc on pourra pas on pourra
pas en donner beaucoup donc le ton
attache à ce point comme deux minutes il
reste deux minutes deux minutes d'arrêt
et même pas en cuisine deux minutes
chance il reste une minute ben sera 24
je pense qu'on sera 24 août n'ont pas
réussi à s'inscrire ils auront ils ont
craqué au moment de l'inscription
et d'ailleurs je suis en train de
regarder
regardez ce qui serait jetée pas
pourquoi mon échiquier de chasse - comme
est devenu plus petit j'ai pas pourquoi
en fait j'ai dû mettre un réglage pas
pratique
pareil je réglais ça à l'avenir
c'est vraiment possible que je sois ban
du life ya sur ce soir à cause du troll
sur l'open title tune et dire non je
pense pas j'en sais rien peut-être je
pense pas je pense pas
du coup ça démarre dans une minute alors
par exemple doublé de groupes date au
fun fun wickliffe aux femmes
cech tueur game the title tuesday lot of
drugs et ceux qui n'arrivent pas trop
histoire si tu ne participe pas au club
bitstream s est mort de toute façon le
temps à démarrer tu tues tu ne peux plus
aller on va regarder la partie entre
jouffre et des buts en 71 donc j'ai
enlevé l'évaluation de leurs dus puisque
j'ai envie de regarder sa tranquille
donc que quatre ou cinq cavaliers f3
carrier f6 hockey une petrov donc là
plusieurs options peuvent évidemment
prendre le pion aux 5 on peut jouer des
quatre où on peut jouer cavalier c3
alors fusé 4 je connais pas mais
pourquoi pas et cavalli g5 à il
transpose dans une science pride liver
attaque et la suite faut faire des cinq
fois plus ou moins forcé puis on prend
et cavaliers à 5
il s'en prend aux fous de cases blanches
qui a fait preuve cette affaire roi
prend f7 normalement là avec les noirs
attention de pas prendre ces quatre
parce que lecavalier menacer la dame est
logiquement ça devrait le faire en fait
un des huit ça me prend
food et 6 ok mais bien joué de la part
n'est noir mais en fait c'est juste une
pièce pour rien enfin ce coup cavaliers
problème c'était vraiment discutable
vraiment discutable ceux qui avaient
progressé à ce que là le problème c'est
que les noirs maintenant faille
absolument pas date a qui vont faire un
nom ils peuvent ils sont pas obligés 1
il va juste faire rager 8 3 h 8 il se
barrer avec les blancs on a juste une
pièce de moins et puis on se
débrouillera a collecté qui ont des cinq
plus tard voilà où on peut même faire
flouer fc un couffin n'importe quoi en
fait toujours un peu n'importe où mais
bon je disais juste bon savent far west
8 fo a fui tout
enfin j'aurais pas joué comme ça mais
c'est juste c'est juste une idée est ok
bon après avec les blancs on peut faire
du fou j'ai 5 kgs c3 du cavalier e cat
essayer de essayer de mettre la pression
vous l'aï dit lui joue absolument tous
les coups que je dis alors je sais pas
j'espère qu'ils écoutent pas le stream
tourner dans la partie mais bon j'ai
l'impression qu'il y avait un peu trop
de délais pour qu'il est temps de jouer
d'un match 4 mais en gros voilà les
plans mais les blancs sont évidemment
très très mal puisque puisqu'ils ont
juste une pièce de moins et une pseudo
activités microscopique m'en fous j'ai 5
assez bien joué ils échangent pas les
dames il attaque la dame les noirs voilà
propose les changes des fous plus ou
moins obligé d'accepter parce qu'on peut
pas déplacer le fou à cause de fou prend
dames vont devoir reprendre de la dame
est bon c'est juste une pièce de plus
alain prend 2,7 problèmes d'échangé les
dames c'est que quand on est déjà
perdant moyen de tests sur les jetez
plus facile clame clic comme à 6 ça peut
être pas mal de temps en temps pour
éviter car elles et b saint caprais ici
c'est pas forcément utile mais c'est
pour pour donner des idées que je vous
dis ça de façon le pion ses sept étaient
protégés par la tour donc là on va
simplement doublé et puis petit à petit
dans la cave ali hafsi s'est échangé
ou touré fitness et puis enfin ici à
plein de manières de gagner ça c'est pas
il remet pas du tout en cause l'
avantage avec les membres et qu'il
essaye de faire un espèce de château je
vais pas mettre le pion c4 et puis
essayer de essayer tout ni remettre la
tour en e1 et puis attendre que les
noirs fasse quelque chose pour passer
peut-être sur afer c6 quand même avec
les noirs pour gagner ce pion ou
peut-être un petit peu un fou ou huit
fois f7 tient faut huit fois cette aide
pas mal c'est réussi à le faire
protège le pion peut-être avec les
blancs des quatre ici tient des quatre
pas idiot du tout d'ailleurs à des
quatre ça peut offrir des contres chance
peut-être enfin des contresens des
pseudos contre chances de semis contre
chances vont sur quatre on prend et on
gagne le pion est sûre puis on prend des
quatre on prend ici et sur des quatre
les cavaliers peut plus revenir en 17
pour protéger ça aurait pu être
intéressant la cave a lieu quatre bombes
auraient juste avoir cavaliers prend des
on perd un pion c'est dommage je ne sais
pas exactement ce que ça a donné
bon les noirs de tout simplement être
gagnant il doit y avoir quelque chose
mais d'un point de vue pratique ça a
posé des problèmes clair peut-être y
aurait pu jouer quatre puis on prend et
fo f 5 5 qui pousse maïs à poser des
petits quand même pratique ce coût des
quatre parce que juste pour montrer avec
quatre marchés pas trop à cause de
cavaillé g4 tirent protégés le pion mais
il aurait pu poser des problèmes et là
je sais pas on n'a pas vu les derniers
coups mais on voit que les blancs voilà
les pièces échange d'une a quand même
deux pions paresse qui peut lutter tati
peut mettre leur enlève de leroy ans le
3 3 f ii roi de trois importants la tour
est venu ce clou et d'air le foot c'est
pas terrible ça pour débutants il aurait
mieux fait de faire pousser 6 pouces et
6 solide autour des 8 pas très bien
placé les blancs peuvent ramener le roi
dans la autour des 5 pour prendre 5 ça
va commencer à faire trois pions pour la
pièce ça commence à faire cher des buts
en 71 ou là la tour prends des cinq ans
lola des buts en 71 au tour f 5 échecs
qui ne le voient pas que se passe-t-il
dans cette partie au wave de bons ils
n'écoutent officiellement pas le stream
tour des deux échecs tour prend b2 on
gagne le pion n'est gagnant aulas le
nombre
de retournement de situation les gens à
ce niveau de la compétition quand même
on s'attendait à ce que je vous ferai
prennent le fou comme quoi vous voyez à
votre niveau
comme dirait fabien parfois il suffit
juste de regarder les pièces emprise en
un coup ça peut suffire
ça peut suffire juste regarder si votre
adversaire n'est pas en train de vous
donner du matos aïe aïe aïe aïe
ça fait mal alors cette partie du coup
complètement indécise je ne peux pas me
prononcer sur cette partie je ne peux
pas me prononcer trop difficile trop
compliqué les noirs sont quand même
beaucoup mieux mais vu le nombre des
rares convois tout peut arriver
étonnant il à 480 points elo de plus
bonsoir il darren haydar haine qui est
la marraine membres membres couronne mon
groupe platine je pense je peux vraiment
pas à 20 je peux vous faire lundi au
compteur mais là normalement faut juste
faire tout reprend j'ai deux gratte et
de plongée et puis après il ya tous les
pions qui tombe mais je comprends pas
trop ce qui se passe dans à l'étranger
de ces faits comme ça ils laissent pas
de marc étions lui arriver dessus après
soit il gratte à deux et il balance le
pion à soi il grattage de il balance le
pion à ce moment là je prendrai plus tôt
le pion à comme ça après boom ça pousse
tout seul mais bon tour pour h2o est
aussi bon toutou gagne mais bon j'en
verrai mon pions là bas vont tout
reprend ce que là ce pion l'avez
peut-être un peu plus simple arrêté pour
le roi mais je chipote
bon bah allez on va prendre l'autre on
va tout prendre là les tontons à les
rois f5 on essaye de monter mais y'aura
toujours j'ai six échecs ou tour à 5 ou
tours 2 on a l'embarras du choix
peut-être pas faire [ __ ] en f3 sait-on
jamais si ce 3e set tour d'essai 3,8 bon
y'a rien mais bon non mais yahia que
d'alain enfin tour à quatre bons jamais
un peu moins mais de toute façon vous
ses 6 contres fin n'y a rien c'est du
chipotage l'a peut-être tour g8 aller il
faut tenter quelque chose
ça sent le fonds puisse contrôler la
case de promotion mais qui peut rien
t'arriver
il ne peut rien t'arriver à part un g5
tour j'ai cet échec 3 8 3 et 6 mais même
ça ça suffirait pas oui torah 5 très
bien joué gagne le pion aussi sans doute
face on l'a dit c'est fini mais jouffre
pourra se mordre les doigts aura-t-il
encore des doigts la fin de cette partie
est là on va prendre le 6 août un f3 et
terminé rideau tout le monde descend
donc enlevé bon voila tu échanges et
tour et tu pousses le pion h le roi
n'est plus dans le carré où le pion à ça
reste laborieux à finir le pion pousse
bon je pense que cette partie on va
réussir à mater y at il d'autres partis
qui nous intéresse
alors on va essayer de regarder la
partie entre pierre de mauduit avec les
blancs et sue sony azerty oui mais bon
la lie à eux l'inde à mots suivants je
pense qu'on va complètement zappé cette
partie on va aller voir colin le poisson
collard le poisson qui est là en direct
contre max ou alors max ou avec les
noirs qui lutte mais colin colin collin
qui colle un filet de colin poissons
blancs qui se bat à fond avec l épargne
à le plan b si ce qui va tomber maxou
qui a essayé de faire cavalier à 4
d'encaisser quatre allers mac sous mac
sous qui se bat à fontfroide et sidi
salem aksu prince et six ans il monte le
roi pourquoi pas aller va choper les
pions non ne te laisse pas rentrer roi
10,6 mac sous mac c'est complètement
raide mais on est chaud pour max ou deux
secondes par coup peut-être foot le pion
à trois si tu peux maxou à fond dans
l'esprit quand on prend ces quatre bien
joué et colin le poisson qui transforme
dans une finale de pions gagnante
quelle technique ce poisson c'est un
poisson pilote assez complètement fini
le roi arrivant au sein qui va aller
choper le pion c4 et ça va être gagnant
bien jouer le petit tour français 4
transformations à finale on aurait pu
espérer pour max ou qu'ils ne le voit
pas et là on pourrait quand même
abandonné avec les noirs ça ne
paraîtrait pas complètement idiot
alors est ce qu il yad autres partis on
va essayer d'aller voir aller on a une
dernière partie cap et louis avec les
blancs contre qu w e 35,9 un pseudo
c'est vrai
original et là ça va être complètement
finie parce que il a beau avoir la paire
de fouilles a plus trop de pions côté
blanc et le pion h devrait devrait
s'envoler
dommage qu'il aurait peut-être essayer
de passer le foot ce côté là mais bon
j'aime la star du x cadre on essaye
encore des micros des micros arnaque
peut-être 3b 6,3 des trois maintenant
peut-être à roye détroit et là je pense
qu'il faut réagir par fou pour un f4
exactement et suroît prendre de foot
prend 1,5
hélas malgré les fous de couleur opposée
il ya quand même beaucoup de pions mais
on n'aurait pas besoin des pions à 1
pour gagner avec les trois pions face au
tout trois pions les face aux fouilles
fou à couleurs opposées ça suffirait
là c'est fini mais bon c'était fini
depuis un moment
allez on va partir vers la deuxième
ronde qui devrait être à parier très
bientôt
allez on va les voir pascal go joueurs
suisses contre david redonne alors que à
oui il n'y a à nous dire bonjour et
bravo kevin pour ton travail tu te
suivront du canada n hésite pas merci à
toi ahmed et pluvieux à partager les
vidéos à fond tout le temps partout sur
tout et sites internet les réseaux
sociaux de partout surtout la vidéo sur
l'alfa gola c'est une vidéo
on espère je pars combien la fée de vue
déjà mon espère qu'elle fasse beaucoup
de vue parce qu'on a vraiment fait
défaut sortir ça rapidement on a bossé
jusque tard pour le faire et on espère
que vous avez vraiment bien kiffé ce est
l'alpha gaulle alpha 0 mais avant c'est
juste une progression de l'alfa de
l'alfa go vous l'aurez compris mais dont
quoi l'alpha 0 on a fait le max pour
vous sortir ça rapidement et on espère
que vous avez vraiment kiffé n'hésitez
pas à partager parce que c'est un truc
un peu qui peut intéresser beaucoup de
monde mais mort d échec puisque on
discute de l'évolution de l'informatique
avec avec un maître de conférences avec
sony c'est quoi le tournoi et alex tu
rates le tournoi mensuel bitstream tous
les premiers jeudis du mois
20h35 donc cette partie on a eu une pirc
et les blancs ont joué la rente avec
kafka qui est pas mal il va sûrement
jouer avec grand regret après balancer
g45 à fond dans l'esprit vrai grand
requin je passe je pense que les noirs
ont mal joué ya quelque chose qui va pas
ici pour les noirs je pense convoquer
sur cinq ont pour au pire faire prisé
des cinq passer en force
moi je pense prises avec f et des 5 me
paraît quand même une option très
logique
il ya peut-être d'autres options comme
prise est fou c'est 4 aussi pour faire
une petite menace sur f7 au passage peut
être pas mal
on peut aussi faire pas touche à rien on
ne peut pas vraiment pas ce qui a pu on
prend
je pense que prisé des 5 c'est quand
même le truc très standard à j'aurais
fait ça assez rapidement
emmanuel 1977 qui unit mauvaises
nouvelles kevin alpha 0 n'a pas sorti la
grotte comme son ouverture favori c'est
ouais mais c'est pas étonnant il le sait
entraîner que quelques heures
emmanuel est donc apparemment ce n'était
pas suffisant pour arriver à la vérité
absolue du jeu alors des prend soin et
juste sur une tactique soit c'est un
coût qui pourrait être remis en question
de soissons il faut prendre et soit il
veut jouer sur le clouage et j'ai pas vu
un truc soit c'est une décision
stratégique un petit peu étonnante tu
des cinq ans le plan est quand même été
bien placé et là les noirs peuvent
éventuellement juste rauque et ça
poussera les blancs a joué avec f5 mais
je sais par et ça me ça me paraît pas
fou
bon après c'est bien pour les blancs 1
je veux pas que vous me comprenez mal je
laisserai les blancs et mon genre rock
f5 et peut-être car elles des 4 tu vois
tu mets le carel sur des 4 après tu
t'installes quoi tu t'es cru ce trader
s'ils avaient peur surprise des 5 et
peut-être cavaliers des cats mais bon
j'aurais fait du dam f2 et j'aurais
chasser le cavalier j'aurais bien aimé
la structure de pions là il s'est passé
quelque chose qui me plaît pas insisté
mais oui surprise des 5 et peut-être
qu'il y ait des quatre que j'avais pas
vu d'ailleurs mais mon affaire d'âme f2
et gérer le carrier plus tard et là je
sais pas je reviens sur ce moment là et
moi et qui a aidé 4 je sais pas
peut-être
damev de vêtements on va peut-être même
envie de faire un truc avec cavaliers
bouge quelque part et c3 après pour
enfermer le cavalier pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas
en tout cas ça aurait paru dans l'esprit
plus logique mais bon alors j'ai un
petit soucis je vais rafraîchir
on à l'évaluation du coût qui est quand
même excellente pour les blancs après ce
coup ipsc accueil france s est ici mais
j'ai teint l'évaluation de l'ordinateur
je n'aime pas trop la voir oui il faut
prendre un cahier b5 pour gagner plus on
éventuellement holt river mais j'avais
pas envie de me prendre car l ie 5 avec
la case de 5 pour le cavalier a prêté
peut-être un peu bloqué mais oui ça
aurait suffi fin pas bloqué mais après
talent fou qui était un peu pénible sur
la grande diagonale donc samarie
légèrement bt je vais peut-être préféré
vie c'est d'enfermer le cavalier je sais
pas mais juste c'est un pas paru top top
le truc avec f5 mais bon maintenant
prêcher pas c'était peut-être dont on
peut regarder en face on a on a les
lignes de l'ordinateur alliés de là on
peut on peut se servir du monde nouvelle
et hitch s.com qui joue tu défends le 5d
prendre 5 et poussé quatre comme dans la
partie et sur fdd saint loup qui n'aime
pas trop ce que j'aurais joué de base à
cause de cavaliers des cas pareils mais
bon maintenant il se met à plutôt aimé
aussi d'un même degré tel apparente qui
donne aussi dans lesquels paru plus
logique de base en me disant qu'il faut
il faire cavalier de au pire
jean roch et je vais au pire faire
cavalier de pour gérer le truc penser à
un truc comme ça
même sur ordinateur tient du cavalier c5
et où tu aurais pensé à un truc comme ça
perso
après l'ordi lui donner un d eux les
fous ces quatre élèves possible rock
ouais possible non mais c'est bien de
façon comme position avec le clouage
juste de base parce que j'aurais fait en
premier réflexe c'est pas ce que
j'aurais fait en premier réflexe mais
après c'est concret un difficile quand
on commande de voir toujours les
meilleurs coups parce que là il va un
peu de concret pour la peine avec ce
truc à aider qu'à toi qu'il faut
toujours se rappeler de cette cette idée
donc demain à roye c2 et au prochain
aimé avoir d'alger cette manne donc
belle victoire de pascal go qui a joué
une belle partie alors lellouche
britannia on va aller voir ce que ça
donne
contre eux coco walker ça c'est fini
tout de suite max roche contrat était un
débutant avait débuté tout à l'heure où
la pollution semble assez agréable pour
les noirs quand même parce qu'on voit
les tours sur la colonne f1 peut-être un
truc comme dame f6 qui menacera tout
reprend avec l'idée d'amener ça une fois
absolument faire cavalier d1 vous peut
être pas absolument mais si je jurerais
cas le jeu qui a aidé un pour protéger
la cage et 5 avec le fou et sur seulles
et noir pourrait peut-être faire un
petit coup de cheat chaque foulée 8
pouces et 6 un peu à la halle fagots
pour replacer l'oeuf ou en attaque et
libérer la case v6 pour la dame
la dame âgée saddam g5 il va peut-être
jouer cavalier g4 bon c'est un peu tiré
par les cheveux il ya peut-être damage 4
tout bêtement qui menacera d'un proche 3
et puis on prend g4 damage quatre là je
pense un peu un peu tiré par les cheveux
et qui avait déjà 4 mais le cavaliere
emprise la tour qui est venu ne protège
plus le pion h
je pense que max roche va devoir avant
démontrant g4 hewitt ou métrage de yack
épreuve de olalalala débutants débutants
les erreurs tout bête de débutants
olalalala les gens il suffisait juste de
prendre en g4 et peut-être qu'il a eu
peur d'un fantôme après prise va
maintenant tu peux prendre un f2 et
c'est fini c'est matt direct d'un point
f de tourcoing f2 et / ou agenda mais
j'ai trois matches aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
débutants est ce qu'il va pouvoir
non il ya plus d attaques a plus rien
c'est fini la dame n'a plus de gaz
débutant en cas qui a perdu par péché de
gourmandise j'ai envie de dire rien à
faire contre hbc des changes les cds qui
amènerait une pièce de plus en défense
mais en avec les noirs mais les blancs
veulent essayer de valoriser leurs pions
éventuellement comment est ce qu'on s'en
sent la dent avec les noirs je pense
qu'il a raison de pousser ses pions
pas toujours si évident à jouer un
espèce de zouzou pour les noirs étrange
situation pour les noirs avec un zoom
faisant complètement inattendu et c3
vient jouer avec elle et prend 1,4 bien
trouver parce que sinon ils auraient
paraît manquer les pro b 6 elle a trouvé
le moyen de gagner avec les pièces
noires et c3 bien joli ce que tous les
autres coûts perdre et simplement un
pion et là le carignan à 4 permettait de
regretter depuis on a quatre et ensuite
de l'emporter il va réussir à récupérer
les pions et a poussé jolie victoire il
reste encore eric cantona contre colin
de poissons alors est ce cas car l ie 8
ici pour les blancs à ça paraît
difficile le roi n'est pas actif qui a
eu toute façon le plus réussi s'était
protégé mais là en plus il ya tout qui
tombe à la colagne pourrait sont
normalement c'est mort c'est colin le
poisson pané les noirs vont aller
essayer d'accompagner leurs pions
tranquillement tueur faire attention aux
fourchettes mais ça devrait le faire
ça devrait le faire pour les cantonales
ils n'ont plus de temps à les bep cap
des 3 b 2
merrick épreuve 4 à peut-être f5
maintenant voilages 5 salaires fort non
s'il l'emporté à lörrach arrivant à 30
pas faire brasser 3 cos qu'avait lieu de
là le roi vient à a2 et a3 e5 maintenant
aller colin de poissons qui trouve du
contre eux je crois qu'on réussisse il
faut et le cavalier qui doit survivre
normalement aie aie aie aie qu'elle
prend b2 roi f7 suis pas sûr que tu es
bien fait de passer le roi du côté ils
auraient dû secret le pion pas assez
éloigné de l'autre côté eric cantona
eric cantona qui s'est complètement raté
je pense à ce moment là maintenant c'est
colin le poisson que si vraiment raté
pardon gd à l'envers mais je pense
souvent un colin de poisson bah désolé à
d'ailleurs commenté les pseudos allons
en faire mais je pense il aurait dû
jouer h5
parce que du coup ça a étiré sa étire
eric cantona qui pouvait pas s'occuper
et du pion h et du pion b et savait
genre 5 qui fâchent k3 prends tu peux
faire h3 roi prend age 2 est en fait tu
peux pas tout gérer
dommage allez on va regarder et ain taya
contre qu we3 159
le cahier française au ghana qualité un
pion mais peut-être que j'ai pu me
tromper
quand je pense que c'est pas évident de
commenter quand on n'anticipe pas trop
les coûts en fait j'ai évité j'ai déjà
arrêté quel point ces deux secousses
étaient d'ailleurs le charpentier mais
tout à fait possible
pas toujours avec la grotte dans le
top-12 ouais ça c'est sûr oui si je rate
étatique pendant le temps le truc c'est
tout à fait normal
alors
donc ça c'est censé être bien pour les
blancs j'imagine ce qu'on a quand même
le pion 4 plus avancé que le pion
décisionnaires contrôle du centre et
qu'on a les pièces plus avancé
les criquets française is intermédiaires
je suis pas convaincu les français 6
intermédiaire j'imagine tu veux pas
donner le fou de cases blanches mais
j'aurais peut-être laissé faire cavalier
à cinq quand même bon mais c'est très
bien je je je sais pas je dis ça mais
peut-être jour à jouer pareil c'est bien
aussi
je sais pas ce qui est meilleur que là
il va pouvoir enchaîner bon j'ai bien
joué à six semaines il faut aller en h4
même 17 et peut-être peut-être d'un f3
mais avoir apprécié a pas des bêtises
avec ça qui marche ça va pas marcher a
eu 5 5 5 5,5 et sur pions 35 da me
prendre 17 vous prend 17 tours en 5
tours 8
je n'ai pas eu cinq peut-être un bon
coup 1
mais concrètement avoir son dame prend
on veut faire tout reprendre cinq direct
mais je vois pas la plus value sur saint
guirec même s'ils jouent à bloquer dame
prend dès 16h17 et tout reprend 2,5
maintenant il ya peut-être juste fou des
six surprend m6 prise et on se dit qu'on
a comme la paire de fou donc que ça peut
à moitié en tout cas compenser ou tour
8000 tours 8 tout à fait jouable aussi
je sais pas j'ai l'impression que ce
truc de 5 ça simplifie trop la position
et on donne notre avantage d espace au
centre
après je sais pas aux requêtes à
meilleure performance kiev alors
meilleure performance en tournoi
officiel français des 2550 ou quelque
chose comme ça donc et très
questionnable cette finale match retour
des 8es jeux seraient dit ok je vais pas
me casser la tête je rentrais la dent
mais la paire de fous je pense que ça
compense quasiment néons quelle idée
simple mais notre pays non je suis pas
si j'aurais accepté de jouer avec ses
pions doublé ces cinq pas mal fait
prendre l'espace info peut-être faire
food et 5 pour passer le fou devant mes
cinq parades jouer car a lieu quatre
aussi peut être une option qui a eu 14
était une option mais le truc c'est que
avec camaïeu 400 aurait pu être
intéressant dans le sens où sur fou ou
cinq on aurait pris en c5 on attaque le
foulon libère le nôtre donc ça aurait
quasi forcée fouet cette et peut-être
maintenant fou des cinq peut-être dans
cet ordre là après avoir un faux calcul
et comme le décès du commentaire et les
échecs c'est un jeu très concret
et on parle t on quand même il a fait
dans l'autre sens où des 50 premiers
tours bouger cavaliers ou 4 mais ici
peut-être qui donne la possibilité fou
ou cinq par est-ce que ça à mon goût
faux seins coupés après ça c'est encore
une autre question mais ça donne plus de
possibilités à l'adversaire
après avoir sur vous et cinq ici afca
tuera foot prend b2 il fait fouet f5
voilà peut-être jusqu'à l'épreuve 6 en
fait on va prendre le pion peut-être
crois j'essais t on sortir un virage 5
et on reviendra en g3 et quoiqu'il y
aura foot range étroit il faut en dessin
qui traîne du bouquet les problèmes 6-3
g7
il faut voir est-ce qu'on peut revenir
avec camaïeu 4 il y aura peut-être du
fou prend h deux échecs tout reprend des
ouais c'est ça ça laisse d'autres
options ce truc d'avoir commencé dans
cet ordre là en fait
du coup aux échecs toujours important il
aurait commencé par camaïeu 4 à moins
que je fasse une erreur tactique ce qui
est je le répète possible il aurais pas
offert toutes ses positions de ses
possibilités à l'adversaire et la cave a
lieu qu'à telenor peuvent faire [ __ ]
en hd et offrant des cinq a minima et là
les noirs ont réglé leur problème sinon
plus problème de structure de pions
évoqué cette finale doit être plus ou
moins égales même les noirs peuvent
prétendre à un avantage peut-être pas
abuser mais ça va
kg 3 m le four angers 6 tu vas peut-être
pu prendre le caté pour prendre des cinq
pour un peu plus asséché la position ou
au quai ou en saucisses aussi normal et
vaut faire tour des huit tours d2 pour
rentrer sur la 2ème juste angers ici
j'avais l'impression d'un peu coupé le
cavalier les oreilles du cavalier un
coupeur d'oreilles professionnel auquel
je reviendrai bien f5 avec le fou tout
bêtement c4i mais les pions sur la
couleur de son fouilles blocs sont fous
pas une erreur grave mais c'est papa
très technique
j'ai pas en quête intérieure a un peu
raté sa partie moment il a joué au sein
qui après dans la finale s'était pas
propre propre
comment le seul joueur qui va vraiment
un pascal beau fait forte impression il
a bien joué son truc qu'il a bien
réfléchi sur le f prend le cavalier ou 4
tout ça il a bien joué le pascal go
pascal ok envoyer du lourd
du coup trois faux f5 le retour du roi
qui revient au centre mais les blancs
les blancs n'ont plus rien ces cas ce
n'était pas très grave de base on a
passé super en guinée pourquoi pas mende
tête on revient aux six avec le fou du
cloud j'aimerais bien essayer un petit
avec les noirs j'aurais bien essayé de
faire un truc genre fou aux 6 h 5 es fou
g4 pour essayer de jouer sur le roi qui
a plus trop de cases
j'aurais pas j'aurais pas laisser faire
ça ok donc la chose importante si vous
avez suivi nos master class avec fabien
c'est de calculer la finale depuis après
tour huit tours ont eu deux et je vois
pas pourquoi elle serait pas bon ça doit
être nul objectivement mais je sais pas
pour qui c'est plus facile de jouer tu
vas me faire jouer avec les blancs en
fait un jouet fait roi f2 g3 repris de
l'espace on chasse le roy on a les pions
on n'allait plus ensemble et je pense
que d'un point de vue pratique en tout
cas c'est beaucoup plus facile à jouer
avec les blancs on a une menace f4 échec
donc ils forcent à faire f 4
mal car à chaque effort la f4 échec
je pense qu'avec quatre échecs peut
éventuellement gagner je veux pas trop
m'avancer mais f4 qui on prend roi f5
ça a quand même la gueule de la finra
lappion prend b3 puis on prend b3 à 4
all que des rares dans cette finale que
des rares dans cette finale parce que sa
fin je sais pas un prêt j'ai pas le
temps de calculer mais ça quand même ça
la gueule d'un truc où le roi rentre
dans le carré à la rage alors là faut
faire f 4 échecs en premier roi des cinq
rois des 3 à 3 le roi va roucouler de
l'autre côté on va encaisser et puis on
va de ce côté là ok je vous invite à en
quelques millièmes de quelques
millisecondes
j'ai envie de dire et donc difficilement
à ne pas faire de gaffe et de vous
donner exactement
l'évaluation une nouvelle fois mais ça
donne quand même envie là je vais quand
même mettre un petit coup d'orly
pourquoi vous dire n'importe quoi de
façon ça va gagner mais là quand même
fin plus on prend et a4 je joue ça tempo
sans réfléchir donc l'ordi hésite entre
f4 qui donnent gagnant pions prend 3,5
et c'est bab à 4 donc les deux été
gagnant donc et noir ont raté quand même
deux idées de gains qui était somme
toute assez simple et les blancs aussi
les ont pas vus puisqu'ils les ont
laissés donc ça vous montre un peu les
progrès qu'il peut y avoir à faire en
finale pour des joueurs kck 1800 sur
chaise comme ce qui permet un bon
classement déjà
et pourtant finale de pions ça me paraît
quand même un peu léger quand même des
choses très très thématique est très
simple
hello bishop btu un petit piège sur ces
sur ces 7 ya pattes mais là il suffit de
faire brasser c'est 3,17 et accompagner
suivante es7 ici des limites en
accompagne le pion j'ai fait cette
annonce à est de fous des chèques mais
je sais que c'est anne zahia avec une
mauvaise technique en finale deux pions
mais son adversaire encore pire alors
c'est la partie la plus longue de la
ronde on va filer vers la quatrième
ronde on va regarder la partie entre 8
and sound why you're smiling parce que
ce sont les deux leaders du tournoi
alors je sais pas pourquoi
pourquoi ça s'est décalé qu'est ce
qu'ils savaient qu'avec et ce qui se
passait ah oui ce cas de m banking
il fait tout décalé lui il est comme ça
à odos imove mike king il a un pseudo
tellement long qui te décale les
échiquiers chess comme c'est pas grave
on va gérer ça
on va gérer ça hop et on va mettre le
temps jusque là bas qu'est ce que vous
voulez son pseudo est trop long ago and
the knife par l' après-kadhafi sur les
trucages cinq échecs est possible mais
aveyron a g6 et tête fois f3 et
peut-être je sais pas mais c'était assez
compliqué peut-être fois f3 ça tenait
peut-être
alors ouais c'est nice note qing
exactement mais c'est plus facile
évidemment de commenter ses beats cela
sans dire de bêtises dans les finales
dans les finales de pions et dans les
positions plus simple techniquement
puisque là par exemple je n'ai pas eu
tous regagné début de la partie mais je
ne comprends rien à ce qui se passe
alors où en sommes-nous
il est 17 hockey c4 intéressant mais sur
un peu folle folle peut-être peut mettre
un cavalier sur le catch est passé 5
aussi intéressant je suis assez d'accord
avec le moose le mouvement le coup joué
par par ethan
peut-être tour ses huit maintenant pour
les noirs je me demande si les blancs et
pas eu intérêt à jouer à 6 d'ailleurs on
donner quelque chose comme d'un mach 4
pour très compliqué comme position mais
ils en sont les noirs une position plus
saine j'aime bien ce plan b 4 qui coupe
les oreilles du cavalier après qu'elle
peut aussi sortir via des deux doit pas
être dramatique et mon petit coup de
tours c'est 8 pour faire prison peut pas
reprendre une pièce sur a15 allait
essayer de s'en prendre aux pions c4 ça
mange pas de campus à tour ensuite elle
sera bien placé mais il a fait à 6 6 et
8 à 6 quand il faut c'était une question
est ce que les blancs auraient dû louer
ou pas j'ai kaboul g4 il à fond dans
l'esprit
mais comme cette dame c'est 8 maintenant
avec l'idée de faire des essais et des
clous et le pion des ja de la logique
dans un comm dams et 8 il ya de la
logique dans un coup comme mc 8 serre le
cou qui est jouée qui a été 2 et là
maintenant ça me paraît assez fort de
prendre parce que sur fou prend dame
prend va attaquer la tour g1 et on va
voir un pion plus en plus quand on fait
céder il pourra pas prendre du cavalier
à cause de 5
ailleurs encore cavaliers f5 qui sauvent
en ré attaquant le fou mais bon on
pourra quand même prendre effet retour
ces huit au pire et de toute façon on
tient le pion ses cassettes tout est
mauvais
des chemins fort ok vous tous chers g5
je pense il veut trop jouer dans
l'esprit et maintenant j'imagine faut
prendre on dédouble les pions et on
s'approchera qu'est donc à sur re5 on a
vu quelques cavaliers f5
on peut aussi jouer
ouais c'est 3 avec l'idée qu'un essai 5
et où il a aussi qualifié 5 dirais qu'il
est plusieurs trucs intéressants qui est
inquiet peut-être qu'elle prend ses 4
mais ça ça a l'air très très bien
non mais là les blancs sont vraiment
foutu le roi est au centre il ya
toujours cinq la fourchette qui traînent
pas non c'est une catastrophe
c'est une catastrophe cette partie selon
le site d'anne d'être fou beckham
j'aurais même dû mal à me décider las à
ce moment là de la partie aura
énormément de mal de me décider je
ressemble tous gagnent parfois c'est le
mans depuis hier donc fou bk très bien
menacé deux c'est pas pour elle a fait
tour g1 ils auraient mieux fait de
roquet saluerait au moins enlevé le
problème du roi au centre ont tout à
tour en jarez même palier c'est la
catastrophe
mais bon donc non pourquoi pas un 5 sur
dans le chat avait peut-être cavaliers
avec 5 qui menaçait le le fou aux 7
après on aurait pu continuer par
cavalier c5 quand même le fou peut pas
prendre ce cas qualité trois échecs
prises le fou reculer plantain car ayant
des trois mais je pense ça aurait été
moins bon après ça allait aussi à tout
va la façon c'est une question de choix
c'est demain le 5 mars un clic & prom 5
attention
cependant un petit quelque chose pour
les noirs parce que position est
tellement ouverte mais il commence à
réfléchir il n'avait pas vu qu'elle
prend 1,5
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe c'est une grosse
erreur quand même grosse gaffe c'est une
grosse gaffe
parti se dépêchent trop de temps qu'à et
c5 dont il reste très très bien roi au
centre enfin m'ont tous les feux sont au
vert pour les noirs mais parfois quand
on fait une gaffe c'est pas facile là je
pense les noirs doivent tenter la tourbe
et un bien joué après de faire j'ai cinq
prises prisé de faire jouer un petit peu
cette tour ce clou à jajpur trouve juste
balancer et g5 dans l'esprit je pense
jouer dans l'esprit à fond et puis voir
de façon est complètement réel bond de
cavalier va venir e4 et c'est de la
merde mais je pense tu dois jouer dans
l'esprit avec et c6 aussi pas mal
j'avais pas vu a très bien joué qu'à
laisser si j'allais rater voyez je les
ai dit que non pas évident parce que
comme vous êtes encore plus difficile de
thorgal est parti quand on est surpris
par les quoi c'est souvent avec des
erreurs mais cas et dessins érotiques ou
calais prend v8 ça reste bien en fait je
pense pour les noirs ça reste potable en
tout cas vous allez prendre la kalach là
j'imagine la fsg 5 maintenant qui veut
même pas prendre la calloc'h il attaque
de l'autre côté vont jouer un quadra
c'est peut-être bien joué dans l'esprit
non l'esprit de se dire le mec en face
on tight on va le découpe d'izard mais
on voyait son envoi est tellement mal
placé on croirait qu'il a fait une
grotte ça qui va le faire gagner
d'ailleurs je pense faut prendre quand
même un jour ou l'autre ici
il prend bekkat oui maintenant que le
cavalier des 5 es parti prend b4 une
nouvelle fois un coup raté mairie
calais.fr 4 ça enlever la protection du
fou et maintenant peut-être tout reprend
b8 gchangetout ambiguïté bon dame prend
ces trois la fin j'aurais plutôt prix du
cavalier en premier et fait roi f1 il
veut pas il veut pas utile et une
pieuvre il ne les change jamais je vous
laisse ses atours rentrée mesdames
français 3 et carré lieu 4 et peut-être
tout reprend f2 échec ici oh là là là je
pense que ton problème de l'échec
pourrait être pas mal
bref deux échecs ça aurait pu être sympa
tâche quand même un les tontons avec le
cavalier e 4 qui venait après avoir si
ça marchait vraiment mais sam est en
danger à leon retourne vers la partie on
retourne vers le direct est maintenant
maintenant maintenant il ya des échanges
de pièces elles cavalli qui a attaqué il
ya david et 8 échange les dames qui
menace s'est parée pour le moment mais
un petit coup dame b3 avec l'idée d'un
baby tous nous de me prendre très bien
réussi mais tout reprend f2
le tour prend un but à l'agent orange
pourrait bien moi j'aurais bien fait
dame ces quatre ans et de fer d'un
prompt à vii est bon à la dame des huit
échecs tempo bien joué de la part de
hard way move the night et à audois une
zone ait qui va finir aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe il ya eu plusieurs erreurs
plusieurs serrures pour les noirs il va
falloir s'incliner ardoise move the
night premiers du tournoi
il est chaud patate deuxième position
max h avec trois et demi on pourrait
avoir une finale la finale max roche
elle est là la finale faut que max roche
l'emportent pour gagner le tournoi
allait max roche
t'as pas le choix
aller faut y aller
il faut y aller tu dois gagner de façon
à la lah nul ne sert à rien pour mac se
chiffre à 4 points il finira pas premier
on sait que dans le tour habite stream
seule la victoire compte l'esprit c'est
de finir premier une ribambelle de
joueurs à trois ils ne peuvent plus
gagner les mecs à 3 donc le vainqueur
sera 60 le vainqueur aura quatre au
moins quatre et demi ou cinq en cas de
nul donc mal aux doigts et move the
night
ben passa passa quatre et demi en cas de
gain il passe à 5 et mac sauf en cas de
gain aura quatre nuls donc le vainqueur
est sur cette partie c'est une finale
c'est la grande finale du tournoi
bitstream
alors là il va falloir envoyer du lourd
f4 et on en donne la case la case dès le
4 c'est de la merde les cas c'est de la
merde menace quand même pris dans le
cinq lacs l'idée de reprendre et de
jouer sur le clouage à presqu un f4 et à
peut-être le cavalier qui varieront de 4
j'ai pas trop aimé le f4 à première vue
et ce coût d'investissement renforce
alors là il ya car il y prend 1,5
éventuellement après avoir et ce qu'on
est embêté par pions prend plus on prend
plus on prend et il y aura le fou
derrière donc & prom 5 qui menaçait pas
tout de suite un sur cinq souffre ou g6
je racontais un peu n'importe quoi
j'avais pas vu cette menace j'aurais
quand même placé un petit cavalier e 4
persos cavaliers 4 6 kg de toute façon
rituelle qu'à radio 4 mais maintenant il
ya peut-être f5 qui rôdent donc cavalier
e 4 ça se sache vous au coude avant à
mon avis et en plus c'est à maintenant
le cavaly 17 qui emprise
pas mal de soucis avant tu as presque
c'était un bon coup quelques atouts pas
je ne sais pas mais ça pouvait jouer le
coup d'avant il y avait le fou emprise
alors il faut aller 5 oui ça j'ai vu
qu'elles font emprise ne suis pas fou
j'ai ici du coup il fait de fouet 5
parce que fo et 4 ce qui a peut-être f5
lankais prend cas tu peux pas prendre du
café puisque ça cette emprise donc
obligé de prendre du plomb une tête
après un coup comme ces quatre pour
pousser pourquoi pas
ou prises prise fou g4 ou je ne sais pas
faut se décider même fou c4 est un coup
cavaliers c4 est un coup aussi même si
cette dame prend des 600 siemion c4
c'est pour aller prendre ça sinon savais
pas trop ce sens je pense que c'est ce
qui va jouer c'est ce qu'il a fait prise
prises et maintenant c'est trois alors
cette paire de fouet ce qu'elle est
vraiment efficace ok caïds et 5
j'aimerais bien mettre le pur ans
s'écarte quand même compliqué
fouquet s'écarter des pas bon non plus
j'aurais bien mis depuis en c4 direct
mais l'armée qu'à trois petites
tactiques du prêt au passage est ok
maintenant fou h4 et n'est pas bien mais
là à ce moment là directement lieu de c3
c4 sa part et c'est quand même
il y avait la logique dans ce coup a
prêché pas et peut-être des tactiques y
avait peut-être des trucs et plus tôt
dans la partie et donc du coup là juste
pour revenir un peu rétrospectivement on
fout jécistes façon sais je sais pas ça
peut pas ça peut pas être le bon truc
pas quelqu'un de direct et sur le cac et
prend le cas depuis on prend mais je
sais pas c'était pas top top 30 a une
bonne tête pour les pour les noirs mais
c'est pas si simple ce n'était pas si
simple de jouer en fait
au retour aux guitares avec les blancs
comment est-ce qu'on joue ça arrête à
mach 5 pas mal on met à ce pion f7
surgissent ici adam prend 1,6 à
peut-être revenir on a fui avec la tour
n'a pas facile à défendre ce pion
l'intention de juger si ce groupe i à
jeun dame prend père la dame dame f8 ça
ça sent pas très loin et touré fuite ça
paraît plus ou moins forcé après avec
les blancs faudrait trouver un moyen de
de créer des menaces est pas évident
mais je penserai fuite
voyez pas d'autres coups en tout cas
ba est imminent en fait les blancs ont
son max en termes d'activité je vois pas
comment on peut créer des menaces en
fait faire plus kiev 5 mai le cas il va
venir en fils et c'est assez logique en
fait de faire f 5 1 mais le truc c'est
qu'on n'arrive pas à faire mieux faire
plus souvent le problème en fait on a
moins de matériel est toutes les pièces
bien placé mais pour revenir en e2 avec
la dame de toute façon et dames g6 ok
mais roy fuite mais enrichissante et
supra f7 du coût d'un v6 pas mal mais ça
crée pas vraiment de menaces mais c'est
peut-être pas mal oui c'est une bonne
idée à sarkozy veut faire à quatre il
faut juste faire à trois comme ça tu
recules temps fou après lé noir je pense
ils peuvent faire tour à cette airwatch
huit tours à 7 pour protéger le pion et
au prochain voyage suite
mais du coup peut-être avec les blancs
ont peu ou et 3 et 3,6 notre option à
laquelle je pense avec l'idée de mettre
la tour en 1 8
qui est fou j'ai trois mois juste faire
d'un bus est je pense est fou et cinq
ans c'est pas mal tenté d'alger 6
écoutez c'est pas mal tenté et deux
intermédiaires why not want to re 1
de toute façon il faut j'avais gagné une
partie comme ça une fois avec comme avec
les noirs enfants rois à suite à un
moment donné le mec a pas vu et j'ai
pris et j'ai pris la dame k faut faire
flouer 5 et il va faire froid h 8 et là
du coup je pensais qu'il fallait prendre
un f6 d'emprunt f6 prise en effet si
c'est jouer la finale mais il ya
peut-être tour 8es droit et pas et
n'arrive pas assez vite au centre
n'eo ket d'amuser 3 du coup meilleur
leroy arrivé pas assez vite au centre
hélas pas évident pour les noirs bien
joué vraiment de la part de max roche
bien trouver cavaliers h5 ok faut qu'ils
bougent la dame quelque part tu attends
g43 aussi pourquoi pas ils menacent dame
prend un fils dame prend ainsi soin bref
si c'est là c'est lui qui se fait il va
se faire échanger mais le cavaliere est
mal an h5
bon je sais pas si c'était si c'était
fait exprès mais si ça marche c'est
vraiment très jolie de la part des
blancs car il ya 5 complètement bloquée
et en fait il ya la menace fouet f7 qui
est assez forte
je passe ils l'ont vu mais il faut être
7 c'est une masse vraiment chiante
ok je sais pas s'il vaut mieux jouer
pion pranger six mois je vous réponds
pranger 6 quand même avec pour maintenir
la menace de gk parce que la surchauffe
7 ses cavaliers f4 et je me demande
d'intuition j'aurais joué pions prend en
disant plus cavalier était difficile à
sauver mais je sais pas si c'est
meilleur il est peut-être tout re 4 et
le cavalier partage et trois rois machin
et lecavalier s'en sortent et peut-être
peut-être meilleur d'avoir fait flouer
recettes
ça a pris ce prisé cette finale a très
difficile à évaluer comme ça en blitz
mais le roi va revenir vers eux deux
verts rêvent de il va réussir à choper
le pion et d'un c'est bien joué vraiment
bien vu de la part de max roche la
finale est bien pour les blancs
apparemment bref de il va faire tout
reprendre de et on peut pas jouer la
finale de pions tour 3 était assez mal
joué je pense tout reprend à eux deux et
maintenant roi et 3
je pense que roy f3 avec l'idée surtout
afin de faire tous rêvent de les gratter
depuis un f4 ça suffisait pas ce qu avec
g3 en fait ils se retrouvent avec des
pions double emploi avec le pion mais
bon il va monter le roi tour est enfin
je sais pas c'est inoffensif
donc ils sont assez bien en tactique je
veux dire que ces joueurs là vous voyez
je vois assez bien en tactique mais il
rate des petits trucs sur des
positionnements de pièces et du coup la
cemac sosh qui devrait remporter le
tournoi mais il va gratter le courage
c'est fini assez joli à un moment donné
il était il a vraiment bien joué là
c'est vraiment bien servi de l'activité
sur d'alger si ce n'était pas si facile
que ça à gérer pour les noirs et du coup
très bien vu de la part des blancs et
max roche qui remporte le tour assure
une belle sur une belle partie très très
belle partie vraiment très bien joué et
chapeau chapeau c'était une belle à 5 à
4 ca de 3 suit pas et ce que tour à 7
aurait été mieux mais bon il se serait
quand même fait planter le fou ans
le fonds a eu 5 n'était pas facile à
jouer peut-être fallait qu'il fasse un
système un peu comme ça pardon pas dans
le système de cette fosse 1 3 h suite
dame j'ai trois maîtres la tour en g8
pour pouvoir replacer le cavalier et
petit à petit repasser ses pièces mais
c'était pas évident il se serait pris du
hf6 à un moment donné c'était difficile
à jouer
les fous très bien placé mais tout ça
parce que la pollution des blancs était
très saine en fait avant à ce moment là
de la partie là il ya un moment je suis
en ce moment là près d'am b6 tourbains
était assez critique
je pense que l'on critique de la partie
et ce n'était pas si évident que ça même
si la position des noires paraissait
assez saine ce n'était pas si évident de
ça que de trouver les bons coups donc
elle prend le 5 mai sa partie difficile
on remet un petit peu ça marchait pas à
cause de prises prisé tour prend là le
fou rester en prise du coup il a fait
bouger 6 mai foulée 6 pouces et par trou
est très bien placée avec les idées de
f5 est ce qu'il fallait faire cavalier e
mais accepter de jouer ça je sais pas
parce que même presque on peut pas faire
fou prend et du coup jouer sa part du
tout intéressant jeu lorsque
l'ordinateur données donateurs préfère
les noirs à la bonne intuition et
propose de faire un truc à jouer dans ce
guide prend soin de commencer par h 6 x
h quatre maîtres juste une tour en 1 8
clément après roy chasse doit pas être
grand chose mais c'était une position
très compliqué je pense pas qu'il ya un
des deux joueurs soient vraiment mieux
visu c'est mieux pour les noirs ce que
le plomb f4 doit pas être un f4 mais
finalement la position est très étrange
et très complexe a joué et du coup ce
n'était pas grand chose dans l'air
l'ordi propose un truc comme dams et 7
pour protéger de cavalli et préparer
cavaliers 4 ce qui est un plan assez
logique pour organiser des plans les
plans qu'on veut jouer éventuellement
ouais j'espère que ça vous a plu
bah je vous souhaite de passer une
excellente soirée
c'était un tournoi assez sympa et ben
ouais donc je souhaite bonne soirée
on se retrouve sur la chaîne bitstream
dans quelques jours ne plaît pas de
mettre des lives de vous abonner
prochaine vidéo ce sera une partie 2
sera la plus belle partie
peut-être de tous les temps puisque
c'était la plus belle partie qu'on est
con et en tout cas pour le moment publié
de alpha 0 donc vous verrez ça samedi
matin là on l'a analysé avec fab et je
vous souhaite à tous donc une bonne
soirée et bon appétit
ciao